hey guys Ryan right over here so there's
a black widow trailer out brought to you
by SML sounds exciting at first when you
say Black Widow trailer then you say yes
I know and you're like oh it's a joke
the Marvel Universe Avengers age of
Ultron is good were Captain America Iron
Man but you want to know why no Black
Widow movie does Marvel not know how to
make a girl superhero movie chill Marvel
gets women chummy in 2016
when they came to life in the big city
Black Widow had it all figured out might
be to call or invented heels elite of a
nasty message a huge apartment great
friends an internship at fashion weekly
take that and put it on the cover of our
magazine black widows life honey
you're putting ketchup on your cereal
from Marvel Studios and the writers of
27 dresses comes the story of a
superhero and her super romance
do it [ __ ] do it
you know anything about you I think your
favorite food is ice cream
hey BW your boyfriend is on the news at
the Fashion Week building I hate to be
that guy's girlfriend
you
you're doing here you know how much that
job meant to me do you need to know my
favorite fruit is thank you falling in
love can be hard but it can also be
thanks for watching mmm that was pretty
[ __ ] funny man
that was pretty [ __ ] funny I love how
they took that typical cliche girl moves
to the city gets a bunch of it's like
new girl Mary Tyler Moore it's just a
bunch of [ __ ] movies that have been
done before it does make you think like
how come it's been so like I know
there's a Black Widow movie in
development right now but it's been so
[ __ ] long like why haven't we gone on
one by now and I really hope they don't
make it so much easier Oh mance movie
it's a funny joke because you know if
she is a female chances are they're
gonna be expecting some kind of romance
just because she's a female but I don't
think that's necessary for her I think
black widows an awesome [ __ ]
character it's cool how she's been a
supporting player in a lot of these
Marvel films and I love how Scarlett
Johansson was willing to play along with
the joke I don't see her in that many
comedies and I think she'd be really
good at comedy like she was really
committed to this [ __ ] she got the
humor down perfectly the timing was
great and I think she'd be great in more
comedies I would like to see them do it
I love how the Avengers are being
promoted through a lot of comedies now I
can't think of two examples but there
was Hawkeye doing the Hawkeye song on
Fallon and then there was you know Black
Widow so I hope we get a third one
that's also just as funny and Thor as a
gay guy if I was gay I let him nail me
with that hammer ah
that sounds painful anyway guys if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the Rio rejects you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
trying to get product placement people
get enough followers then I get a do as
little work as possible by posting a
[ __ ] photo so if you companies are
watching I'm ready to promote Ryan give
me a shout out so I can masturbate to
you say my name I'm joking
but I am hard Wow out of all the shout
out requests this one I can do baby can
you help me out with this one this guy's
name is Ali cult heart and he wants me
to give him a shout out so he can
masturbate to me saying his name so can
you just start saying his name along
with me and make like noises oh cord
hard you get me so hard court hard Oh
Ali you can go on my back alley you know
what I mean oh god let's [ __ ] the
court hard alley court hard alley court
hard yeah yeah it's really hard what do
you want looks like we can't [ __ ]
anymore without people knocking on our
door